[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS Saturday
morning and welcome to the dish grab
your fishing gear today we're diving in
for all things Seafood from crab to
squid and from coast to coast we head to
Texas where a chef combines his
Vietnamese fruits with Cajun fare and to
Maine for one of the most delectable
lobster rolls in the nation but first
Jeff floor meets a farmer turned
restaurateur who now runs one of the
most iconic oyster bars in Rhode Island
you ready he's ready Mogwai has to
approve all oyster that's right he's the
head of operations over here
on a sun-soaked New England day Perry
Russo took us to Potter Pond just off
but sheltered from the heaviest waves of
the Atlantic
the ideal spot to harvest a food that is
changing everything here
oysters
right off the back of the boat
that's an extra gives it an extra flavor
that's probably not the cleanest thing
in the world right not bad
add that to the list Rosso started
fishing as a boy and digging little neck
clams when he was 12.
he graduated from the University of
Rhode Island after studying aquaculture
then started a small oyster Farm in
2002. so we got a leading space to grow
nice you got little shrimps jumping
around in there Rosso operates Seven
Acres of water farming with more than 16
million oysters plus bay scallops really
interesting animals they have eyes they
have 32 sets of eyes on the top and 32
sets on the bottom and you can see them
they're like little blue specks Russo
has also built a huge nearby vegetable
farm so we have beets salad greens
couple varieties of kale over here we
got our peppers and our Tomatoes started
and salad greens over here as well as
the asparagus all of which Supply his
restaurants which has become a Smash Hit
for diners across the East Coast
matunak Oyster Bar you're not a chef no
you've never been a foodie
I I've become a foodie how is the Raw
Bar Feast over here by now though Rosso
has taken his broader message Global
delivering TED talks about the
importance and sustainability of
aquaculture to feed a crowded and
hungrier Planet shellfish farming is the
epitome of sustainable agriculture
aquaculture sounds like agriculture
aquaculture is agriculture we're sitting
here you can sit here and look at and
look at where your food comes from line
of sights right it's important I mean we
have uh you know the vegetable farm and
the oyster farms all within a mile of
here
to be able to see you know where your
food is coming from see the farmers
coming in with the oysters putting them
right in the fridge and serving them
right here you know it's a unique thing
and I think you know oyster Farm geek
thought is you know this incoming tide
is delivering food to my babies out
there you know one of the great things
about oyster Farm is going to have to
feed the oysters they eat naturally
occurring phytoplankton in the water so
this is delivering food to the animals
it's lunch for them right now it's lunch
for them and it's cleaning the water so
it's uh beneficial there are a lot of
people who come in who just don't won't
eat oysters right do you make it your
mission to try to convert them well I I
do try to get them into oysters in our
oysters and the tunic oysters are uh
they're a petite oyster so they're not
big so they're a little bit more
palatable for someone who might be a
little wary of eating oysters it's
almost like it's like a like a Gateway
oyster the Gateway oyster is what I like
to call it this right Rosso has built
his menu slow and steady the breath of
which we were able to sample starting of
course with oysters so these are the
tunics right here are those are the ones
we Farm raise out in Potter Pond I'm
digging in yeah try one of those
great thank you good sweet
and the crisp is Sweet It Is crisp yep
to accompany Russo's best seller we also
had him a tunic special passion fruit
oysters with salmon eggs and cucumbers
soaked in sake
if you prefer your oysters cooked there
were the bourbon oysters
also an asparagus and tomato salad with
vegetables from his farm and a local
seafood salad
calamari oyster stew with a rosemary
cream broth and this quinoa crab dish
that blew our minds look at this sucker
so you've got quinoa avocado crab
drizzle over the top is we have a lemon
zest aioli there
oh that's fantastic nice
so good
not to be overlooked the tuna with
Creole mustard and mashed potatoes and a
ridiculous Lobster Pizza he recently
debuted it's a pizza we put on the menu
during covet I was researching what's
the most popular takeout food pizza and
so I said I wanted to make the best
seafood Pizza in the world and I think
we might have come close to it we got
some proscute some truffle some arugula
on there it's really delicious it should
be illegal this is crazy how good it
really is that pizza is absurd for
desserts there was a blueberry crumble
animatoonic signature key lime pops
the full scale of Rosso's creation here
is amazing even though he still feels
like a little kid scrapping for Clans
just to make a few bucks you talk about
this a lot about your fear of failure of
not
succeeding do you still feel that way
yeah yeah absolutely
you're never satisfied uh I I don't you
know like to think of myself as someone
who's never satisfied but the reality uh
might be that yeah and in the end
people get a healthier ocean because of
it and and good food yeah there's
definitely so we should enjoy your pain
crawfish in Cajun Country
[Music]
Chef trongwin gave up a career in the
casino industry to follow his passion
for food and has paid off he was
nominated for a James Beard award for
best chef Texas in 2020 and his
restaurant crawfish and noodles has
turned into a destination for locals and
tourists alike Janet shamlian got a
taste
a walk through the busy kitchen of Chef
trong win is to find him wildly
outnumbered by Crustaceans of the Gulf
hundreds of fresh crawfish and crab
filled the kitchen
but it's never enough
they always sell out at Houston's
crawfish and noodles a modest strip mall
restaurant that has more accolades than
some of the country's finest dining
spots including the most coveted of all
a James Beard nomination for best chef
Texas in 2020 quite a payoff for a guy
who spent 30 years in the casino
industry talk about a bat with no formal
training and a love for food he wagered
his life savings on opening a restaurant
you left a really good job to do this
very much yes is something in me telling
me that you know
win or lose is a gambler of life was it
a gamble of passion yes also
Chef Wynn is credited as one of the
creators of what's become known as Viet
Cajun cuisine
this is back in the refugee camp wow
influenced by his family's cooking as a
child in Vietnam before he immigrated to
the U.S it's a mix of Southeast Asia and
the good old American South
the Cajun part is whole boiled crawfish
the Vietnamese influence a soupy soak of
butter and garlic these are like mini
lobsters you know that's that's all we
do handpick that's everything like this
this side this isn't your traditional
Crawfish Boil for one the secret blend
of spices aren't added in until after
the Mud Bugs are out of the water
okay now we put the flavored sauce in
okay that's butter and garlic and garlic
the imported butter important butter let
me get a little bit more seasoning in
there
the first one is to lightly mix it now
now it's free seasoning yes
[Music]
actually yeah you got your hips going in
there this is how it's supposed to be
done
how is it different from a crawfish boil
in my backyard when you open it up yeah
you will see a big chunk of meat still
crunchy very very crunchy never yet
never overcooked so that is the big
difference
it may be his signature dish but it's
only one of his create
how do you create it do you just there's
is there a family recipe is it trial and
error like what is it for you it's just
food come in my mind naturally so when I
thought of something that I like to eat
I normally think of how
to put them together Chef Wynn says he
likes to experiment putting his own
stamp on dishes like stir-fry noodles
chicken wings spiced crab claws and a
Viet Cajun Lobster
his favorite dish is always his most
recent creation currently a Viet Cajun
salt and pepper Dungeness crab
meat right there
and then you suck the sauce from the
outside
get a little bit of everything this is a
little something sweet yes it's like a
blend it's a blend of spices as any
crawfish Enthusiast knows there is a
proper way to eat a Mudbug I've had a
fair share of the Southern Delicacies
but my technique needed Improvement so
you hold a coffee like this
so that's how you suck the head
we'll see all juicy and seasoning
kicking in
yeah
a little spicy a little and a little
messy don't wear white uh Corey vins
um Vin is in the front of the house
Corey the back of the house to help me
out my wife Pierre take care all the
paperwork and also helped to prep to uh
when we're busy
so kind of a family business
Chef Winn working alongside his son in
the kitchen even his mom helps
when we work in a kitchen we like the
machine I mean the Fun Run Like Crazy
the back is like rolling
business sank during the pandemic like
restaurants everywhere but customers are
back the loyal Houston area crowd and a
never-ending flow of tourists some come
right from the airport customer is like
our friend and family they very
supportive it's now been more than
made that way Jordan Lee gambling
regrets from leaving the casino industry
no sometime I look back and say wow
back there I only went suit Thai the
pretty walk away you know walk around
talk to people shake hands sit in the
night restaurant dining with all the VIP
but now I carry every single disc out of
the table to show it to the customer but
I'm very proud of it because that's what
we make that's what I made so I'm very
proud
thank you
summer is finally upon us which means is
peak season to indulge in a lobster roll
whether the crustacean is drenched in
butter or Thai curry paste there's a
delicious version for everyone Maracas
on a roll
every summer Route 1 in Wiscasset Maine
becomes what locals call gridlock with
view three lobster rolls please as
pilgrims descend to Feast on Red's
classic lobster roll and from Mount
Vernon Illinois
and I come to Wisconsin every year just
eat at Reds hello hello George and
Allison Stallard came all the way from
Austin Texas we're at Lobster Camp right
now which means going and getting
Lobster All Around Maine for a week of
course the onion rings ketchup I also
have an in-house blue cheese sauce oh
yes yes Debbie gagnon's father Al red
Gagnon bought the shack 40 years ago Red
secret recipe there's no secret give
people the freshest food in Pilot High
I'm just going to grab a little more for
this one no they don't hold back at Reds
here it is right here each roll is
stuffed with the meat of a whole lobster
so buttery and delicious oh my gosh
Lobster a once reviled Seafood fed to
prisoners long ago clawed its way up
from bottom feeder status on the menu
the first person to serve lobster in a
sandwich may have been Harry Perry of
Milford Connecticut who grilled one up
in 1929. it became the Hallmark of our
restaurant Wendy Weir is Harry Perry's
granddaughter we were known as the home
of the famous lobster roll
lobster rolls across Connecticut have
been served hot ever since the best
today the crustacean sensation is
sweeping the nation
then we create a Thai curry paste way
over on the west coast Chef Brandon
kita's lobster roll takes on flavors
from the Far East so it has Ginger
lemongrass kafir lime garlic at LA's
hanoki and the bird we don't have a real
history of lobster rolls so it's nice to
be able to have freedom with creativity
and smack dab in the middle of the
country at Josh Thomas Smack Shack in
Minneapolis lobster rolls served cold
are hot don't you know we go through
about 2 000 pounds of lobster a week in
in the summertime when we're busy ton of
lobster a week literally a ton of
lobster are we
the bread's local this is probably about
a four pound the lobsters flown in from
Maine people say how far is the ocean
from here where the ocean is you know an
hour and a half away by like the
Concorde wow by you know but the space
shuttle that's like two hours okay all
right all right but a really ambitious
Lobster could make it here if it went
through the Atlantic through the St
Lawrence Seaway over millions of years
get here when Toma first sold his role
out of a food truck seven years ago
minnesotans were confused I think
oftentimes people would come up to the
truck and think they were getting sushi
but soon enough they took to it so no
pressure but let's watch you take care
first bite ever like a lobster to melted
butter
wait wait
deliver your verdict when you're ready
saver saver
what do you think very good another
lobster roll lover
thank you for not saying it tastes like
chicken
after the break a restaurant committed
to using indigenous ingredients this is
the dish
foreign
ly from Cleveland Ohio Chef Steve Phelps
moved to Florida 20 years ago and he
opened his popular restaurant indigenous
since then he's been a James Beard
semi-finalist for best chef in America
twice for his inventive seafood dishes
Jeff glor was lucky enough to get a
reservation
so this is the Pompano
nigiri ready for this one Jeff oh my
goodness so we've got sweet soy we've
got a Szechuan chili oil and then
there's a Yuzu gastrique which is a
Japanese Citrus that's really really
bright and you got the sea purslane on
top with some fear of cocky with sesame
seeds and Nori so just get it all in
your mouth it's a work of arts right
here
wow
the impeccable balance that Steve Phelps
brings to his food is something he's
been cultivating since he was a teenager
but really took off about 20 years ago
when he and his wife left their home
outside Cleveland for what they thought
was going to be a short trip to Florida
I think we spent an afternoon that day
at the beach and saw a dolphin jump up
in front of us and we're enlightened
said wow this is pretty nice fast
forward almost 20 years later and I'm
sitting with you outside my restaurant
now indigenous was opened in 2011 in a
residential neighborhood in Sarasota
which has long had a thriving Arts
Community Phelps set out to create a
seafood Oasis the word indigenous when
people think Florida they think Citrus
and citrus is not indigenous to Florida
correct indigenous ingredients here you
know for Florida really were the rice
and the corn and things like that and
it's tough because there's a lot of
confusion with that and I have to say it
as a chef because I get a lot of calls
and they go do you make Native American
dishes all day there but indigenous to
us means that it is from the era or
native to the area and that's what we do
with all the food that we can
how do you describe your food philosophy
my food is food that's recognizable and
I think responsible is a name that we
like to use one example his support of
local
farm-raised fish which haven't always
had the best reputation that is changing
fast as conditions inside aquaculture
Farms improve dramatically and it's the
global demand for seafood has doubled in
the last 60 years I'm so fascinated by
the technology that they do these
recirculating tanks that they use these
fish never stay in the same water the
feeds have come so far advanced in
technology with what they're utilizing
in those too we've got so many different
species and I rely on them as a
restaurant owner because my menus have
to continuously have an item on there do
you think fish farming is the future
it is
I'm afraid of what's happening out on
our Waters the pollution in the water
the quote is for the fishermen they're
all starting to get pollution's getting
higher quotas getting smaller and we're
going to need that protein
from a relatively small kitchen Phelps
turns out an incredible variety from all
that Seafood to these ridiculously good
Beignets there you go Jeff try one of
those bad boys
oh my Lord whoa
and there's more we'll let him do the
honors on the larger spread he prepared
we've got some Cobia hot dogs with a
little local sauerkraut and some
Cleveland bertman's mustard we spice it
with some pastrami spices a little baked
shrimp and scallops with Everglades
butter this is Barrel fish over a bacon
potato Latka with a little Yuzu
hollandaise and jerk relish our house
pickles
this is redfish over Congaree and Pen
Midlands with a little Nashville hot
butter and a little hot drizzle those
are our Beignets we discussed this is a
green curry fish dip that we do here and
a little bit of Sesame Nori crackers our
tribute to Strawberry Shortcake is that
panna cotta with some Florida
strawberries and some sweetened biscuit
crumble
we have that nagiri with the Pompano
earlier a little Thai crispy pork belly
with fish sauce and Thai fish sauce
caramel and a baked egg and then that's
our wild mushroom bisque which is a big
staple here we've made that for years a
couple cold Brews from Colusa our local
Brewery and then of course I have to
have Buckeyes on my menu being a Ohio
State boy and so we've got a little
raspberry jam and some banana Cashew
Crunch underneath those now I work with
a Michigan fan I'm I'm a little worried
about how that's going to go over but it
looks delicious well we've had quite a
few Michigan people in here say that
they really enjoyed it if Phelps can
convince his arch enemies to eat and
love his food there may be no limits on
what he can shoot for Buckeyes and beer
that's a thing right it is today shall
we toast to the beer and eat a buckeye
cheers
though for him it's always going to be
bigger than just what's on the plate
say that that's education is just as
important as the actual food that you're
serving here what's the most important
message that you want to get across
making your your dining experience and
your choices good for the planet I think
that's one thing that we've always put
emphasis on here people ask a lot of
questions in our restaurant and I'm
lucky enough to have a staff that wants
to educate a guest as well as I do and
our wild fish tonight red snapper from
Madeira Beach caught off a boat called
the fish Busters and if you know that a
chef is educated and a staff is
educating can teach you about where
things come from why we utilize it and
it's good for your body and the planet
that means we just did our job today
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Michelle
Miller we'll see you next time for
another helping of the dish